il n'y a plus de vie dans les rues de
stepanakert le quotidien se vit sous la
terre et dans la peur surtout un pigiste
arméniens de la région nous a fait
parvenir ces témoignages de civils qui
se morfondent dans le sous sol de leur
immeuble à appartements nous n'y ai dit
qu'elle s'était réfugiée dans une église
à 10 km avec ses deux petits-enfants
mais elle a été bombardée vendredi
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pu vous allez
voici ce qu'il reste de la cathédrale
historique du saint-sauveur
parmi les décombres les fidèles prient
encore comme pour un miracle soude le
monde doit voir ce qui se passe ici
depuis la reprise des combats et
reconnaître notre indépendance dit le
père andréas ils blâment la turquie pour
son soutien à l'azerbaïdjan contre qui
les séparatistes arméniens et se bat
pour préserver la république
autoproclamée duo kalaba cette
boulangerie de la capitale est un des
rares commerces animée elle a été
réquisitionné pour nourrir les soldats
mon petit fils est au front mon neveu
aussi tout le monde se bat dit elle pour
notre territoire
ça fait cinq jours qu'elles font du pain
et chaque fois qu'une bombe éclate on
pense que c'est la fin mais nous voilà
debout c'est notre instinct de survie
car tout indique que les combats se
poursuivent malgré un cessez le feu
négocié par la russie une trêve qui
n'aura tenu que quelques minutes à peine
et qui semble avoir été violée par les
forces arméniennes aussi ganja la
deuxième ville d'azerbaïjan a été la
cible de bombardements dimanche en
pleine nuit on y croyait au cessez le
feu et c'est pourquoi nous sommes
rentrés dormir à la maison dit cette
femme azéri alors que ses voisins
consterné pleure les victimes dont cette
jeune femme d'un côté comme de l'autre
la misère de la guerre s'est installée
la trêve s'il y en a encore une et
fragile et nous nous battrons jusqu'à
notre dernier souffle dit cet homme pour
notre république et pour l'arménie
notre nation ici tamara alter escaut
radio-canada moscou